[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Justin is
in Houston Texas hi Justin how are you
good afternoon Dave good afternoon Jade
are youall doing good today we're great
how can we
help well um I'm I'm calling today about
my cousin Brandy um when you're when
you're an only child your cousins are
like your de facto siblings and my
cousin Brand's only L three weeks
younger than me so we often joke that
we're the closest things our families
have the twins we grew up very close and
she has two kids right now a 13-year-old
son and a 5-year-old daughter about two
years
ago um her son Brandon wanted to start
making his own money because they live
pretty poor they he only makes about 18
or 19k a year and he wanted money
because he wants to go he's a he's a
Astros fan he wants to go to games he
wants a jersey and he wants to work and
make his own money and he Bor he
actually handw wrotes letters and
there's his neighborhood next to the
apartment they live in he went around
Distributing these handwritten letters
hey I'll mow you lawn for $40 give me a
call and he started getting calls he
borrowed my lawnmower for a while
started making his own money he bought
his own and even looked up YouTube
videos on how to take care of it how to
oil it and take care of the blades and I
was so proud of them so proud of him for
taking this initiative cool well a
little while later the money he had in
his drawer from working his mom took it
saying well no what do you mean I didn't
know you had this much money we got
bills to pay and and about and and so
much so he started hiding what he was
making yeah about a year about a year
ago he actually had enough save to buy a
riding lawnmower he bought it from a
pawn shop for about $900 again I'm
thrilled with them he's looking up
YouTube videos taking care of it how to
maintain it and he brought my flatbed
trailer just so he could keep it at the
house so that way whenever he had a
client I would help him out in the
weekends I just go over there hook and
book and so Mom is going in there Mom is
going in there and taking his
hard-earned 10 15
bucks I'm afraid it's worse than that
Jade how much is he
making it doesn't matter the fact
that um about six weeks ago he came home
from school and the mower's gone she
sold it saying that quote we needed to
pay billt um she sold her for $500 and
then so she's making she's making like
you said 18 or 19,000 a year is that
what you said yes what's at he cred he's
devastated she works as a hotel desk
clerk but it's not at a fancy hotel it's
like one of these mom and pop things on
side of Houston and at this point
whenever he comes home his mower's gone
he's crushed he's devastated I go over
there because I'm that close to them I
care about him I want to find out what's
going on all she tells me is that we
need to pay bills I need $500 so sorry I
had to tell them and she's Unapologetic
about it at this point she he's crying
right there his eyes are like Cherry
he's devastated he just stands up walks
to her and says I can't be your son
because you're not a mother right now
you're a monster and storm
offl he he might have thrown in a
four-letter word or two which I'm not
just stay on
radio and at this point you're standing
there witnessing all this to this lady
who's like your sister and you said what
to
her at this point I was trying to say
why would you steal from him what are
you doing and she said two things one
you can't steal from your kid everything
that is is mine I needed to do something
that's what was available I had to do
what I had to do and then the second of
all was and I swear this is a very small
defense for her that is how we were
raised that's how our moms raised us and
that's how our grandmother raised them
was whenever you start working you pitch
in and there's no age requirement when I
I got my first job at 15 the first thing
my mom want to know is okay when are you
getting paid I we got this bill to pay
yeah and and we were talk not to
question it so really I don't know what
to to tell them I don't know what the
quote Ramsey solution is on kids working
trying to earn their own money should
they pitch in or is the money theirs I'm
just I'm not lost words because I don't
have kids
myself I'm a little I'm a little I don't
even know what to tell her at this point
I care more about their relation I don't
she cares what you think yeah I don't
think she does either and I know she
does care what I think I mean what she
part of I think she blames me for this
part of because I'm I'm apparent he
thinks I'm instilling ideas in his head
that he doesn't have to pitch in that he
gets to keep all the money what she's
saying is like this has been a
generational thing this is the way she's
been raised it's the way you've been
raised your grandparents have been
raised and she thinks it sounds like she
thinks that this is right and like Dave
said I don't think she cares what you
think um at all like she thinks that
this is the best way to go uh obviously
I can look at the situation and see many
many things wrong with it a she's not
earning enough money she's it sounds
like an able-bodied healthy woman who
could go out and earn more than $18 or1
19,000 a year so it sounds like sheble
this next week
yeah yeah working 40 hours at Target she
could earn more yeah so um I mean run
over to run over to Walmart they're
paying 20 bucks an hour it's a lot more
than she's makinging now and she could
work 60 hours a week before I take money
from my own kid MH so she has character
issues you can blame it on your family
tree if you want to but just because um
misbehavior is part of your family
heritage doesn't mean that it's a good
thing it doesn't make it okay if
anything I think it would make you want
to do better and do differently for your
kids yeah I mean there's a lot of a lot
of most of us have something somewhere
in our family history that we absolutely
don't want repeated yeah down the down
the family tree right so uh that's a
character character flaw including
stealing from a 13-year-old now if you
want to go down the path she's going
down philosophically you can go down
that path but it requires more courage
than being a thief it requires just
sitting down with a 13-year-old and go
hey we don't have much money we want you
to pitch in and so if you if we can you
know some of the money you make you
ought to pitch in here in the family and
demand that of him you could do that but
that's different than stealing out of
his underwear drawer or selling his
lawnmower when he's not home yeah that's
cowardly she did that because she knows
she's
wrong I'd probably bring that up if it
were if if it were my brother or sister
I'm really trying to put myself in your
shoes if it were my brother or sister
and I saw that I think that I would
approach it in that way like what Dave
said I'd say look if you need help
around the family which by the way you
shouldn't but if you did why can't you
be a grown adult and model what a what a
grown adult conversation would be like
in say to him hey this month is tight
would you mind helping out or I need you
to help out or I'm going to make you
help out but at least do that to his
face instead of just scarfing his stuff
up number one but before all that you
know what would what would I do if I
were in your shoes Justin um it sounds
like you have a fairly close
relationship to her and it sounds like
she has uh she she's off base and so you
need to take her to coffee and say all
right sis here's what's going on you
don't make enough money your job sucks
and you don't work much you need to work
more and you need to get a better job so
you don't have to steal from your own
kid and I'll help you do that I'll coach
you along sis I'll help you get into
financial piece university I'll help you
get on a budget I'll help you start
acting like an adult so you're as an
adult not dependent upon a 13-year-old
to quote pay bills you ought to be
ashamed of yourself putting your family
in that position when you're able-bodied
and can make enough to take care of your
family instead of scarfing front your
family and so that's me and her having a
conversation at coffee but there's
nothing that requires her to do that in
the law and you can't make people do
smart stuff if you could I'd have been
out of business a long time ago